would you pack up and move down to San
Diego I live there full-time yes
you'd be ok not being a part of
Vanderpump rules anymore I mean that's
season 10 we're talking about bro
scheana Shay are we still going my Shay
I feel like I have to ask you this every
time it's still my legal name okay and I
mean when I changed it legally and
professionally a few years ago it's like
I'm not gonna go back to Murray or
legally go back to my maiden name and
maybe get married again one day I don't
know probably not but well you never
know I want to talk about there seems to
be almost a justice for Sheena campaign
this season yes I love it you do love it
okay you absolutely how are you feeling
about how you're coming across this wall
I mean it just gets worse every year
why is this year so much worse though um
honestly I I don't know it's just like
every season it's just a different style
Sur dress and a different boy I'm
awkwardly flirting I'm divorced I don't
know if you know that no I do doesn't
define me oh wow yeah it feels like
we're seeing a lot of you with the
newbies and not a lot of you with the oh
geez I'm the only one still at server
why is that you told me Brice I don't
know I would love to be on stage in
Vegas in my podcast studio with my
boyfriend like my actual life I would
love but in this world I am at Sur okay
you're at Sur experiencing a lot of time
with these newbies giving some of the
newbies a hard time look it was it was
all in fun I apologized very shortly
after but also what you didn't see is I
was being directed into what she was
supposed to do from Peter from other
managers they're like go make her do
this go make her do that so I was just
the messenger okay but I was just like
you know what if that's my job today to
be the [ __ ] trainer then so be it and
it just so happened that Dana started a
day before charlie so she was the one
who got the gun today
that's the reason you went after Dana is
just because she started first I we just
didn't click and it literally had
nothing to do with max it's just we just
didn't vibe right off the bat and with
Charlie I did with Brad I did and with
Dana I think she has a similar
personality to like Stassi and Lala and
that's just not the type of personality
that I'm drawn to it's usually the one I
run from so right off the bat we didn't
hit it off but you'll see as the season
plays out that we do become friends yeah
here you become friends and then maybe
things take another turn after that
there's there's some bumps in the road
still definitely but I mean I talked to
her last night and we're gonna do a
little Palm Springs trip there on okay
so in a good place now yeah okay takes a
turn takes turn back you know I mean it
things always take a turn I could take a
turn next week again you never know
that's the world of Vanderpump rules
yeah it's not a jealousy thing I'm sick
of people thinking it's a max jealousy
thing he comes in this group for two
seconds and it's like it's frustrating
I'm sick of everyone trying to make it
like at the jealousy things it's not
okay why did you get so upset when you
were pushed on if it was a jealousy
thing with her because I was jealous
that she was getting her career filled
and that everyone was going to her
comedy show and all of these things it
was like you've been here for two
seconds and you're getting all of this
that I've worked eight years for
meanwhile I'm just at Sur and flirting
with a boy sir boy no Vegas and podcast
no anything else and so it was a
jealousy thing but it had nothing to do
with max it was so frustrating because
everyone's like you're jealous I'm like
yeah but not about that like can you
just listen and no one would listen to
me and I just I needed to speak out
about it because I'm like I will admit
to you when I'm wrong if I am jealous if
I'm overreacting like I can admit fault
I'm not above that at all but I'm not
going to admit something that's not true
and sometimes like especially with Lisa
I love her so much and I love her advice
and all of those moments I get with her
but she has this way of telling me how I
feel and what I want and that drives me
insane I'm like oh my god no one is
listening to me have you been able to
have that conversation with her though
of like stop projecting my feelings onto
me no no now private the reunion okay
something to look for yeah so excited
still on the west side yes you're not
gonna move to the valley with everybody
else
hoping moving to San Diego before you
see me in Valley Village okay that's a
big statement I mean yeah so my
boyfriend loves
[Music]
let's talk about your boy he's not on
the show oh thank god
do you want him to eventually be on the
show honestly yes and no very small yes
because I genuinely feel this is the
only real true love relationship I've
ever been in so I would love to show
that but at the same time I want to keep
him as far away from all of it because
you know one little Aussie joke and
that'll be the whole season of whatever
way it's gonna get twisted and I just I
don't want that for us he wants nothing
to do with the show he's friends with
everyone we've all hung out several
times and he's boys with all the boys
but he really doesn't care to be on it
so we'll see why do you say this one
feels different from past relationships
I just know that I've never felt the way
I feel and he says the same thing
there's just this spark that we have
that I've never experienced before and
it's like every relationship I get in
it's like this is the happiest I've ever
been because obviously I am going to
date someone better than the last I'm
not gonna date down so of course
everyone I would hope would make me
happier than the last but this
relationship is just very different in
all of the best ways I've never been
made to feel so secure and wanted and
loved and just treated with the utmost
respect and little surprises and things
that I've just never had and I'm only
saying this because you're asking me but
I don't brag about him like oh my god I
got into a rabbit hole last night of
season six and seven and I was just like
all of the he saw one scene of me with
Robin he's like babe I'm like I know I
know
cringe where these like get it we talked
about having kids and getting
and we're looking at houses together Rob
and I am named our first daughter
Madison marine parks falada but do you
now understand having shown him those
episodes of past seasons why you get
labeled quite crazy yeah I get it now
did you boy crazy
I yeah it's just like I totally beat you
didn't see in the conversation with max
when I am like calling him out about all
this stuff I'm like but look I go at the
end of the day I was in Vegas that
weekend and from chippendale to Magic
Mike to DJ I was like wow Sheena you are
a little boy crazy he was not wrong and
I took so much offense to it and I'm
like I just need to embrace it I'm
capitalizing on that we have boy-crazy
merch coming up in hoodies and then rock
is my number one Supporter with this
he's been the one dealing with
manufacturers and like finding the right
fonts and the right style of beanie and
all of this means like look you can be
boy crazy because you're with a man now
okay yeah and hey if you guys can work
together that's another I know exactly
and like there's so many things that
have been like his ideas and it's just
like having someone who like wants to be
a part of my life but doesn't need to be
on the show or involved social media or
anything like that just genuinely wants
to be a part of it and help me build my
brand I never had that before
so where is this thing going you said
you don't know if you want to get
married yeah a little South San Diego
would you pack up and move down to San
Diego yeah I lived there full-time yes
that would mean largely walking away
from the show this group well I am
renewing my lease in Marina for another
year okay yeah so I'm not going down to
San Diego just yet you'd be okay not
being a part of Vanderpump rules anymore
I mean just because I live in San Diego
doesn't mean you know I mean that that's
season ten we're talking about broke
okay let's get through nine first or
hold me on eight yeah we're only on
eight so this this wouldn't be for a
well over another year if at all how
long has it been now um almost six
months
yeah it almost feels like now it's like
not crazy because I mean we were a month
in and we were in Bali and Australia and
yeah you started this relationship by
traveling the world together is not how
most relationships start no but after 10
days of 24/7 together and not a single
even slight disagreement I was like wow
I've never done that with anyone not
even my ex-husband we're taking things
slow and quick at the same time we are
both divorced so to jump back in it's
like you know we need to make sure it's
right not rush it but at the time feels
right then why not but I don't know does
the fact that both of you are divorced
also helped as you know now like what
you want what you don't want a shared
experience in a way yeah 100% I mean we
both know what it's like to go through
all of that and that's not something
either of us ever want to go through
again so I know you froze your eggs I'm
actually getting ready for round 3 round
3 yeah why three rounds because I
unfortunately have a very very low
almost non-existent fertility numbers
for my age and after the second round I
was like wow I have 16 eggs this is
amazing and my doctor's like 16 is good
it's not great consider a third and this
was something I'd talked to Brock about
and he's not weirded out by it he's not
afraid of it he absolutely supports it
and he knows down the road I mean if we
have a chance to make a good healthy
embryos the scientific way then so be it
but I'm not gonna get pregnant on my own
it's just not in the cards for me unless
there was a miracle but you never know
but very very unlikely you're taking
your future indigo in hands yes and T
there's another cast member who's gonna
do this with me who can tell ya stay
tuned
what do we be surprised to find out who
it is okay but Brock and you talked
about having kids yeah do you have a
timeline at all of when you think that
might happen no now we're just enjoying
life right now we still want to travel
we want to build
businesses together whether that's maybe
opening up another gem and me investing
or just we're putting a lot into my
YouTube channel right now because I just
really want to show the side of my life
that nobody gets to see unless it's in
an Instagram story here and there and I
just really want people to get to know
him and regardless of if there's a
season 90 news on the show you're not
gonna see that for a year from now so I
just really want people to see this
relationship because it is the real deal
and to be in control of how they see it
that too that definitely helps okay I
want to dig into some other drama I'm
holding on the show
Jackson Brittany doll the pastor drama
in the past so that you had until like
three days ago right I'm wondering like
why it took police are coming to you
guys I'm not talking about this are you
kidding me is that Tom and Ariana seem
to be the only people willing to speak
up to them about it at least on camera
why wasn't the rest of the group being
vocal about it I honestly didn't look
into it whatsoever it's not my wedding
not my business I think God so blown out
of proportion I'm like okay get where
Jax is coming from like why didn't you
speak up sooner but I get where Tom's
coming from he's like thought you
handled it and now you didn't so like
let's do something and Sandoval is the
type of friend where he genuinely is
happy for his friends he's not jealous
of his friends success or love or
anything he wants the best and even if
that means some constructive criticism
or saying things that no one else is
gonna say I appreciate that so much
about him and he's actually made me a
better person a better performer by his
constructive criticism he's given me and
so I think people should embrace that
more instead of shaming him for being a
good person and a good friend okay
performing are we performing more are we
doing more music I feel like we need to
need another collab with you and Lala
[Music]
the thing with Lala I love her but she
says one thing to my face and another
thing behind my back and we're literally
sitting on set of the like a boss you
know Mike
we're a good duo I would love to do this
mother thing she's like yeah yeah we
shouldn't I'm like but the thing is
you're gonna get home and make fun of me
for suggesting this and nothing is ever
gonna come out of it and nothing's come
out of it okay
yeah we're seeing that shade of Lala
maybe a little more it pops up in the
most recent episode where she says
Ariana wants everyone to fail but then
said this is a safe space you can trust
me that's very flip-floppy
um I actually haven't seen that yet but
I saw Tom on watch what happens live so
I saw that little bit of it and I was
like cool I got it that's my night
tonight I'm catching up on my episode do
you watch the full episodes now are you
still fast-forwarding just to your
scenes
so I'll skim through just to see overall
what's in it but then I will watch it in
its entirety more than once
okay yeah yes and the thing is I would
fast-forward through most of my own feet
okay so that got misconstrued and that's
what I even said like on the reunion I
was like yes they do but I also
fast-forward through mine because mine
are so cringy but also there were like I
remember scenes it's like Stassi and
Patrick and I'm like they're not even
together anymore why do I care to see
this guy be so rude to her like I don't
need to see that I'm like I don't care
like and I know they did the same thing
with me but now I am in a good place
with everyone I love our show and I do
watch everything not everybody in the
group is in a good place though now
which is if we know Denzel do you stand
in that whole thing I mean if I had to
pick a side I'm definitely on Kristen's
I talked to her almost every day and
she's one of my very closest friends but
I mean I I love Stassi and Katie and
were in a good place we're not best
friends I don't think we'll ever get
back to that but I'm in a good place
with both of them
so I mean I still love them but I'm team
Chrisman team Kristen okay
last other drama happening in the group
we're seeing James
say really nasty things to Raquel oh I
got text that night - okay yeah I got it
from a night out one yes love you you
where are you I'm breaking up with you
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
it makes me literally want to throw up
like I wanna throw up right now
it seems like there's no coming back
from treating a woman like that Raquel
is a saint
she's a very forgiving person and this
was the breaking point for her where she
was like okay now here's an ultimatum
like you either stop drinking or you
lose me because I'm not gonna put up
with this anymore she had finally had
enough but I think up until that point
in the same when I was with Shay for so
long it's like it is a disease and
people don't realize that I didn't even
realize it when I was in the marriage
until after and I'm like oh my god like
there there are things that like you you
can't help unless you want to help
yourself and I think she saw that with
James and just wanted to stay and just
fix him and help him but then it's like
once you reach your breaking point you
can only be disrespected for so long and
I was so proud of her for standing up
for herself and speaking up and they're
in a great place now there's still half
a season left to watch I think there's
more than half price you say your big
breath there are you scared about
anything what's coming up I mean yeah I
just knowing what I filmed I I know at a
birthday party because it wouldn't be
Vanderpump rules if there wasn't a
breakdown at a birthday party I have a
very vulnerable probably one of my most
vulnerable moments I've ever had on the
show with Lala and I'm not looking
forward to seeing that but I am because
I just finally just threw down all my
walls and I'm like yeah I'm depressed
and I'm not happy and here's why instead
of just acting like no I'm fine I'm fine
I'm fine I was like I'm not okay I was
not in a good place last summer I
was struggling with a lot of anxiety
depression I just wasn't in a good place
personally and no one was understanding
that everyone just thought oh you're
jealous of Dana and I'm like no I got a
lot of other things going on
it's not about Dana can you give me some
insight I know we'll have to wait and
see everything that leads to that moment
but what you were dealing with the one
big thing was going through a second
round of freezing my eggs I mean filming
a reality show sober like Bravo to Lala
and now James and other people who can
do it because I mean I don't drink a lot
but I do smoke weed and that's the one
thing that helps me with my anxiety and
so being dead sober injecting myself
with hormones waking up alone every day
like putting my body through this for a
maybe baby like it just it really took a
toll on me emotionally and I just I lost
it it makes perfect sense isn't all
right well I'm glad you're in a happier
place yeah yeah looking forward to the
YouTube channel yeah and I guess more
than half of abruzzo oh my gosh I know
[Music]